what up anime fans it's goes on and kid
Kai here and today we're discussing
episode 41 of Dragon Ball super before
we start I just want to say shout out to
all the Christian Orthodox is out there
celebrating Easter today all of anime
uprose Christian Orthodox so we're
definitely celebrating it anyways let's
get back to business kid Kai initial
thoughts well okay let's start things
off for the episode starts off with the
Omni King mm-hmm where to begin with
this again I've discussed this so much
in the last one I don't want to smother
you guys with this but the thing is
again I'm not satisfied with the way he
sounds sound so childish to me honestly
like I have to mention this I don't want
to smother you guys too much with it but
like it's so underwhelming and honestly
to be frank quite frank with you after
the last step so I'm really not
surprised what do you think yeah I think
that definitely that's as shown to be
like the creator's motif I guess often
we're seeing this more and more even
like them like the really strong guys
seem to appear childish and now even the
voices child there so definitely not
loving it but we'll see we'll see the
story behind that because we haven't
seen any power from him we've just seen
the fear other people have and Kim Chi
raise an interesting point like why have
bodyguards if you're the strongest you
know it it happens like they're strong
characters who sometimes just don't feel
like fighting so they have bodyguards
but who knows maybe he'll be revealed to
be not as powerful as people think right
well I mean depending on which
translation you've seen with which subs
it's been said been stated by beerus
that he could wipe out all 12 universes
with the blink of an eye so I mean at a
10 stand out in an instant he is
basically the god of the Dragon Ball
whatever you want to call it it's not a
universe because a parrot it's universes
dimensions he has the omnipotent he is
the Judeo
Christian version of God and from what
we've seen so far um all in all I'm not
very happy about that not that there's a
God in there but I'm not satisfied with
the fact that there's such a character
so far out that like it's becoming it's
unrealistic on goal to beat right like
it's a like Goku can potentially like
defeat him right it's just too much he
can destroy the whole the whole reality
daddy yeah they basically introduced the
character that Goku will never reach
it's just not pause we which which we're
not really fans on right it's like you
want the go close we'll see bout goku's
motivation has always been to be the
strongest warrior so as the Cheetahs and
now it seems like you're getting
stronger and stronger we see remember
when Shenron who was always considered
like so powerful he's like sweating when
he sees betos right and then we have the
exact same situation right now when
beetles sees the Omni king so or Omni
God is it what is it I'm the king Omni
got one of everything various on
translation but the soul pretty much
it's it's getting kind of ridiculous you
know as soon as as soon as we get
someone possibly catching up to betos
now we have someone who's completely out
of Venus's league so that wasn't great
yes I agree with you and the thing is
we've always had an introduction of new
characters and they've always been gaps
and big gaps but this is seems to be a
gap they can they just simply can this
is there's just simply no way there's no
way to surpass this like key every
single character is an insect to the are
making key just blinks and everything's
gone you can no matter how he can wipe
you out of existence no matter how
powerful you get because that's how
strong he is he has no limits as powers
are unless their infinite from what what
has been implied and you know that's
kind of ridiculous it's kind of going
back to like the way comics were when
they introduced the present or the one
above all is like these judeo-christian
version of God and it's like he's so far
out above strong like you don't like you
don't need to introduce those kind of
characters you know it's cool I don't
mind having like divine hierarchy and
all that that's cool I've always liked
like studying God's of different
religions and stuff like that personally
but like to be honest with you they
should have just introduced a character
that was let's say going back to the
scaling thing where go kuh was a six
beers was a time which was a 20 maybe
the Omni King if they wanted him to be
the strong it should have been sorry did
I say we was at when T I'm in 15 sorry
um we're wheezes a 15 dominating should
have been like a 20 or a 25 but you know
they may mean I like so you might as
well by August infinity right now they
just it for now it's an infinity you can
turn that eight sideways and make it an
infinity sign right now because that's
just beyond ridiculous well let's let's
look at the rest then so on the King
leaves and then we go on to get the
Dragon Balls right and I know a lot of
people speculated that the Dragon Ball
was the planet and it definitely turned
out to be that way you know that was
cool that was cool maybe a little
unrealistic just cuz it's like what are
the chances but you know [ __ ] it is
dragon ball super this isn't this isn't
like Tolstoy we don't need to have it
all mapped out beautifully and
realistically um but what did you think
gave Kai of the dragon not but honestly
not bad like it's interesting that he
has like the golden color and stuff like
that it's almost like an Egyptian theme
that sticking to it econo reminds me in
a sense because like the winged dragon
of raw and you go with me and remind you
of blue-eyes White Dragon mixed with
winged dragon of ron i remind ya that's
exactly what ever my face completely
completely like Blue Eyes White Dragon
it's pretty cool you know I like you see
me like a planet resemble Saturn in this
guy's galactic side yeah literally it's
like for us Saturn was like smaller than
then like a little piece of candy like
it was it was crazy so really the the
dragon is
huge and the animation was really cool
like I liked it a lot there was the
whole planets the seeing galaxies it was
really cool and the dragon I gotta say
it all it's as as poor as the king of
all was like that's how good the
animation for the dragon was which at
least it didn't upset there it wasn't
like a little turtle dragons yeah wasn't
something stupid like the major like
kind of like life at it I'll give him
that yeah we'll give him that um what
was I going to say okay so it's kind of
it was also kind of interesting weird
that they got swallowed by the dragon
and then like they ended up with like
some kind of nucleus version i don't
know that was a bit of a confusing
explanation and so what do you think of
beer is his wish that he made to restore
the earth six universe in universe 6
earth and have it resemble the universe
sevens earth where they have great food
what do you think biros like we've seen
this character in anime before right he
he doesn't want to be considered a good
person like he wants to look like he's
you know up to no good doesn't really
have feelings but this wish definitely
shows that he is a caring selfless
person like he even though his brother
one and you know brother rivalries I
have a brother like it's it can get bad
but even though he won he could have
done whatever you want he chose to
replace earth for his brother so it
really shows that this character I mean
we I've seen in uptown that like we knew
it already but it reaffirms that he's
not evil right there's a union there's a
yang his role is to be the destruct ER
but he's not an evil person it's
definitely clear and this shows it
better than anything else and we've seen
it throughout so I think that's cool
that it's definitely showing us that you
can't judge a book by it's cover right
in the first movie we thought oh man
this guy's like this guy's bad that the
end of the movie were like questioning
it and now we know for sure
day he's not a bad guy yeah I think he
personally likes to keep his stance on
things neutral if you from the freezer
movie where he tells fruit fries like
he's neutral he takes no sides in
anything like that he does right yeah
ever does a lot of times and you know
what's interesting he he restores life
and restores the planet which is
actually quite opposite of what his job
is as this hockey shin or god of
destruction which destroy is supposed to
be destroying life throughout the
universe um God all in all it is what it
is it's interesting night law brought up
it's beautiful huy's brings it out of it
right we still ways teases him about it
I love it I love it because he's like oh
now it does nice to you to do is like no
I just I just did it be so he'll owe me
one you know hey he won't admit that
just doing something guys but we know it
is and it makes is so much sweeter when
characters like that act nice right I
agree with you and you know he loves to
keep his tough persona because you know
he is supposed to be the most feared of
the gods so far um run total amna Kings
been shown even though i do think
personally it's a bit ridiculous how
they react to him i don't know why
they'd be so scared of him even though
like he's been shown to be
extraordinarily friendly by shirking
goku's hand and everything like that i
love Shoku like that was hilarious he
just lifts him up okay like oh man that
bats bats Goku for you like he just
doesn't care and it goes to show the
Omni King doesn't really care it's it's
people who supposedly know his role but
I mean really he doesn't seem like a guy
who cares about roles that much he's
just nice and he brings up the idea a a
tournament with all 12 universes which
is very interesting let's let's talk
about that a bit I'm glad you brought
that up because that's probably the most
interesting thing that I've seen thus
far mention in the episode and like I am
personally very very excited I'm going
to make a prediction right now
the gray the great i don't know the
grand supreme tournament of all 12
universes my prediction is you're going
to see it a lot a lot of terrible
character designs that's my prediction I
know Allah true it's a bit of pessimism
but it's not like super peasant
pessimism because we've been showing it
throat super a lot right now especially
the last like 10 episodes we've been
shown a lot of bad character designs
yeah but hopefully like as we've seen
with hit and the dragon it all will have
a plenty of good ones to balance out the
bad one yeah of course we'll see
definitely good ones too and them I'm
psyched I like about that site to see
hit again I like shrimp I can't wait to
see him again on wait to see the
strategies that other universes will use
because I feel like almost one universe
is like one way of thinking almost and
now I feel like all these different
universes are gonna have all these
different styles of hi I agree which is
gonna be very it's gonna be interesting
remember guys six and seven are mere
universes so they're very similar to
each other right so these other
universes could be completely different
right and yeah so what some are same
right because like 1 and 12 know much
other time in 11 from what we've seen
yes we only seen six and seven right
right so these from what we've seen are
going to be completely different and
it's gonna be like a really huge chance
for the Creator to like practice
exercises creativity so I can't wait to
see what's gonna happen oh I love it I
can't wait I hope it's not been like the
one dark after this one the one that's
coming up sick a three or four like
episode uh like development of character
like character development that's what
it is um I hope it's not the one right
after I hope there's like maybe like one
or two after that arcs doing other
things and then returning to that yeah
cuz Gokula needs to get stronger there's
no way he's gonna stand a chance yeah as
things stand right I don't want to just
to be like a tournament format for
majority of the anime but exactly even
though we love tournaments like I need
old dear God Dragon Ball Z whenever went
to a tournament like when cell
proclaimed the tournament I went crazy
because a lot of tournaments but we
can't have just tournaments right i can
i can i love the two like i watched dr
on Dragon Ball had the most tournaments
more than dragon ball z and like the
thing is is like it's nice but you don't
want to dominate the whole thing you
want like an in-between thing kind of
the way Dragon Ball did it um but yeah
I'm excited it's going to be great you
know we're going to see some
extraordinarily powerful characters that
may even surpass dearest because if
you've seen the dubbed version I don't
know how accurate is but the bureau said
that they've spawned some warriors more
powerful than him and Goku so we'll see
what happens yeah I can't wait alright
so that's it for today guys what's your
concluding thought milosz yeah that's
okay yeah he just revealed my real name
that's ok doesn't matter um my final
thoughts is I give it an eight out of
time yeah that yeah definitely I that
agree with that eight out of ten solid
episode guys thanks for watching like
comment subscribe and we'll be at back
at you next week see you later space
cowboys